[Music]
in special package news submitted by
Andy new in Halla know when cat hair
links a woman to bombs that were mailed
to Obama and the Texas governor oh
that's dope I don't understand what that
means
traces of the cat hair yeah how does it
what cat hair DNA yeah oh [ __ ] we caught
her dander smart I mean there are other
things too but the the main like
clickbait thing about hold of the cat
hair hold up
why do you trying to bomb Obama he ain't
even the president no mosa no sure you
sense it when he was president oh ok I
was like kind of like behind yo he's all
like I'm gonna get take George Bush off
that I was I used to rule you must be
reading the newspaper very late yeah and
it's kind of odd to because they're
saying her motivation to do this was for
some reason she blames Obama and the
state attorney general she blamed them
for the fact that her ex-husband didn't
support she didn't get support from him
like they don't support the support that
she didn't he wouldn't support my dreams
of being a ballerina it's all your fault
Obama yeah somehow like they're saying
reasons are unclear how this connects
but that's the reason odd Bernie was
Julia Oh me
her name is Julia pop this is what she
look like she looks like a cat lady she
really does she has to be a
stereotypical cat lady look that's her
and she's a cashier at Walmart striped
shirt with [ __ ] dark brim glasses
yeah and so yeah she ended up mailing
these homemade explosive devices and
they're saying that things that they
found were a salad dressing cap from a
bottle that she had bought for her
anniversary dinner
oh she's married her ex-husband now see
that's why I'm like Adam
it's kind of confusing but based on that
and on as well as a cigarette box can we
go back a little bit how do they know
that the cap was from a that it was
specifically from the day of her
anniversary I have no idea they saw the
receipts this is the government yeah
they know everything the webcam did the
FBI gotcha well they do explain how they
found how they linked the cigarette box
because she also used the cigarette box
for her explosives they're saying that
there was a barcode that the type like
that number is linked to a store that
sold that cigarette box and then they
they found that that one makes sense but
the fact that that's a bottle that she
used for dressing on the day of her
anniversary very radical find that salad
dressing too in the fridge without the
[ __ ] cap monster who does that
heyyo who does it not me everything in
the fridge has a cap on it in your face
don't even look on this side of the desk
look for something that I will say this
I hate it when people do that when they
leave stuff open because the fridge
absorbs all flavors yeah and then you
have a salad dressing that tastes like
kimchi anchovies are penetrating into
that's why Korean people have kimchi
fridges when you leave it aside like the
child he never wanted oh that's
interesting because it's capped but it
still smells through the jar yeah and
then she also left on the box one of the
boxes she left in obliterated shipping
label but they were still somehow able
to make it out that I had her address on
it
what you mean obliterated because that's
what they're saying like it's
obliterated but I got like a permanent
marker to scratch it out or something
yes she was like I did this because it's
like how does it obliterated to be still
okay maybe yeah yeah she just didn't do
a good job
she used household items like DIY style
instead of going to Home Depot and
getting all the items fresh and brand
new and bringing it back and using
gloves she acted like go and rummage
through her garbage and recycle and all
that stuff is a bargain farmer bargain
bomber that's what happened oh yeah
name this music the bargain bargain
bother you guys wanna blow things up for
Jimmy's like the Martha Stewart [ __ ]
for bombs and [ __ ] imagine she has a
YouTube channel are their bomb YouTube
channels they create you know they
create a lot of [ __ ] like videos and
stuff and propaganda if they have videos
I know who they actually make videos to
show people how to make their own do
they have YouTube thank you so the bomb
if not you're dead he'd like for boo
yeah but this so now Julia she's facing
six charges including two counts of
transporting explosives with the intent
to kill and injure why you do that yeah
and if she's convicted she faces decades
in prison but they aren't they did
mention though that the Attorney General
at that time a mr. Abbot he opened the
the explosive package but he didn't open
it in the way that it was intended to be
open so it didn't explode why is he
opening it
don't they got [ __ ] those bomb people
no no they didn't know that it was a
bomb yeah he probably didn't open it
this way he's probably one of the guys
that cut the side of the package and
opened in that KitKat bars like all four
at once all those [ __ ] weirdos yep
well yeah like break it before you open
it no huh like the key cop are the
others
yeah they just bite the hole like it's a
harmonica species stream yeah oh yeah
you're that person cow yeah I also find
my mom Walter it tastes better when you
string it though yeah I think it does
the change of the texture takes away too
much time
just bite it I'm on both of your guys's
teams you got to know my kick at the end
I'm just chewing off all like the top of
it and I leave the cracker and then I
need the card
nice and love Street side is weird wait
a minute wait a minute win it I'm sorry
what but you [ __ ] can't each stream
cheese because it takes too long yeah
what string cheese though was that [ __ ]
I used to love because my mom would
never play it for me and all the white
kids had it yep yeah it's healthier too
though what string cheese is it holding
like regular cheese it's less in fat
yeah I think you've got low-fat string
cheese but that's it's just it's not
that much more it's mozzarella that [ __ ]
has hella high fat doesn't it yeah is
that not that great oh no I love string
cheese by used to watch all those kids
with that [ __ ] I never got that [ __ ]
dude and they're just right in front of
me [ __ ] white Devils I'm over here
with my love box that kimchi fried rice
[ __ ] you
did you ever take gummy would you ever
take gummy bears and turn it into taffy
well when you get a gummy bear and you
pull it and you keep pulling and pulling
a Napoleon and it turns into like this
really stringy taco with marshmallows
you have childhood memories that nobody
relates to do you guys remember a
birthday we had to pray to your mom
remember Christmas we had no Christmas
when you open up the Christmas present
and then your mom gives it to someone
else
let's pour it you know blood sports so
dope damn it never still never seen it
yeah you're watching blood sport
tomorrow night cuz I'll send it over to
KC for utilize it's very inspirational
yeah he has time you should watch it I'm
like it's a great way to learn about
other cultures too is that the word it's
a little classic where's though is what
movies in the beginning where
he has like the military he has like
Asian parents but then he has like a
sports bus boy oh my god what the [ __ ]
did you just say she was adopted by
Japanese people no but he's American
he's a Tanaka how dare you he's American
right right but he got adopted but he's
an American in the movie yes he's
American military weird
he also played guile a US military guy
even though he's French its [ __ ] it's
not weird it opens you up that to the
different culture of French adopted
abandoned child by Japanese Americans
that don't really have a good Japanese
accent you know in bloodsport that's the
first time I ever heard a agent kid make
fun of a white kid and he goes huh yeah
didn't work though he was the white kid
that got picked on by Asian kids there
was the opposite yeah and he did the
death touch let him Mack and he would go
in his backyard and grab the koi which
is where you take a bunch of bricks
right and then you could target which
brick you want to break so he would he
hit the the stack of bricks and he shot
at the bottom one but they met the death
touch it's pretty old video yeah it's
like in the 90s or late 80s it was a
cult classic though I don't know I don't
know he's a real acting at all and he
used to play it on TV I remember like
channel 13 channel 5 and by the way
Frank Dux is a real person that's based
off a real life story a real person in
France and there is a Hong Kong
full-contact fighting place yep and the
guy he said that he knocked out Frank
Dux in the real life like blood sports
he actually fought in the UFC and he got
his ass whupped fun fact
fun fact oh yeah how did they do that
did they find it with the cat hair also
under the shipping label there was a
single cat hair and then once they trace
it like getting all these clues from
both packages they ended up tracing it
to her and then they use a DNA sample
from her to cat one of the two cats they
ended up seeing
it was a match oh my god I think this is
what happened she probably did one of
those 23 Emmys for the cat I was
thinking about doing that for my dogs ya
know that you could do the DNA to figure
out what breed your dog is oh yeah so
they have one for cats I'm assuming they
make him spit too I should might be like
17 in me or something I don't know how
many chromosomes they have yeah and then
the the FBI just logged in found your
[ __ ] yeah I know cuz I was thinking the
same I'm like I know all the cat how did
they just treat you the [ __ ] Siamese
[ __ ] it's either that or there's
a database of [ __ ] cat DNA which is
probably gonna be hard as hell to find
stabbing [ __ ] cat lady's [ __ ]
harridan nice try we're voted for Obama
see cats are [ __ ]
Chauncy ass [ __ ] Chauncey and
they're evil they're not I went here so
one time TIFF wanted me to house it or
cats it so I went to her house to make
sure that they were fed and alive even
though I was like cats are evil I had
like my back against the wall the whole
time because I'm like aren't always
[ __ ] are from so they were hiding of
course and then once they see me they
ran and they like jumped thought to the
[ __ ] screen door that you had and
they were like climbing on a bunch of
little kitten I made a cat friend over
the last week so like me and Jess we
were in Texas and we wanted to walk
around for dads neighborhood so he went
in and did like a little forest walk in
a straight cat popped out wasn't it
really straight because it had a little
cute little bell it had walked with the
[ __ ] dog yeah the cat walked with us
like throughout the whole entire
neighborhood just like a dog like just
following us everything it was [ __ ]
awesome
there are a lot of cats are like that
though cuz its friends I just remember
when I was going around to like second
Street in Long Beach there is like this
old couple that would that would just be
walking and you would see two cats
walking alongside them without a leash
and really all these cats are so cute
like yeah these cat likes to like walk
us down to 2nd Street and
then like when we're done like they'll
actually wait for us and they'll come
back in the wall oh yeah cuz they're
territorial huh I believe it's their
cats but then like they just chill
around but they're like they walk with
them and then they walk back yeah I
think us their territorial because
that's what happened to us - we went to
this block yeah and then the cat oh and
the cat got another cat homey to come
you are cuz really what was happening
that was a threat on your life
calling for backup I guess he is ever
psychic commercial with Chuck I just
don't like cats because they [ __ ] really
weird
[Applause]
girls in pain yeah but I'm trying to
sleep a [ __ ] and then [ __ ] hobble oh
dude is like shut the [ __ ] up yeah and
it goes on my life ugh you're like 20
minutes and [ __ ] you jealous
I'm telling you [ __ ] somebody who
sounds like that that she's good
[Music]
[Music]